Thank you for your interest in Nucleus
Medical Media
we hope you enjoy this video explaining
our production process.
Our animation team produces a creative
brief for you based on your initial proposal.
This brief includes the goals of your
project, the intended audience,
style, and what to expect from the final
deliverable.
Our writers work with you to create a
script to the action in your video.
This script includes narration if you
want it. Before the script is finalized,
you will have the opportunity to review
the script for accuracy and visual flow.
Next we use the script to build models
for your animation and create a storyboard.
At this step we'll point out key frames
to describe our concept of what's happening in the animation,
and what the narrator is saying at each
point. You will get another chance to
review it to make sure we're on the
right track.
We will advise you to check for items
such as accuracy,
object placement, general textures, and
camera angles.
From there we create what's called an
animatic.
This is a rough draft to the animation
that we provide to clients
as one more review step before the final product.
Watch your animatic for details such as:
how objects move, timing, transitions, camera motion, and narration quality.
Note the colors will not be as vibrant
as the final animation.
When you're happy with your animatic
we'll move on to the final animation.
Our animators enhance your animation
with elaborate textures,
lighting, and special effects, creating an
animation that exceeds your expectations.
When your animation is finished you'll
take a final look to make sure it's
everything you wanted and more. Our post-production team adds your logos,
and delivers the animation in the file
format you need.
You have complete control of this fun,
creative process.
If you're interested in working with
Nucleus, please contact us using our
toll-free number
or visit our website.